the sound
ah hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to we all
have those holiday specials we love even
if they're not really the best whether
it be nostalgia creativity or some sort
of surreal intrigue we all have those
specials we know aren't fantastic but
something none the less draws us to them
they're not good enough to be classics
but they're not bad enough to go
unappreciated either there's a certain
magic to these specials that keeps us
coming back and this Halloween we're
gonna look at what it is here today so
get ready to share with adequacy we're
looking at the top 11 best ones why top
11 because I like to go one step beyond
so sit back and enjoy the top 11
Halloween guilty pleasures
however Tiny Toons night gallery the
reason I put this one solo on the list
is because well it's mostly pretty good
really shortly after Tiny Toons went off
the air and Animaniacs was catching on
in fact there's even a few cameos from
them
obviously nature is fun even whittles us
all this satirizes every gooey thing you
can think of night gallery Twilight Zone
Casper Edgar Allan Poe Nightmare Before
Christmas
anything and everything Halloween and
the writing is some of the show's best
these satires are right up there with
mel brooks or the Zucker brothers for
example they do a parody of the
Spielberg film duel about a trucker who
randomly tries to kill a guy when the
driver looks in a bar to see if he can
spot the trucker he actually spots the
truck itself having a drink
that is incredibly clever there's also
introductions to classic literature with
some of the best visuals the show ever
pulled out the attention to detail in
what their satirizing is beyond
obsessive it's amazing how similar they
are to the original source material so
you might be wondering why is it on this
list at all well a few sketches maybe
are a little too smart for their own
good
like the Tara 20,000 feet parody is
literally nothing but Star Trek jokes
get it cuz it starts chatter when some
of the impressions are a little hard to
get I'm still not sure who this is
supposed to be you ever wonder what
exactly they mean by more Tim Conway all
three of my fans who remember him
nevertheless it's not nearly enough to
take away from appreciating this fun
collection of beautifully animated say
teenis the misses are minor but the hits
are just too good to overlook that's a
now there's sadly no DVD release of this
special but if you can hunt it down on
VHS do it it's definitely worth the
search
Gino's costume show were hot
number 10 the Halloween that almost
wasn't this is about as low-budget as TV
specials get but they do still match to
make the most of it
Dracula summons all the famous movie
monsters together for Halloween but the
witch is fed up with Dracula's treatment
of them and goes on strike if he doesn't
start playing nice he refuses leading to
a wild goose chase of him and the other
monsters trying to force her to change
her mind
it's about as silly as it sounds but
what makes it enjoyable are the
performances this isn't any kind of
great writing but everyone's dedication
to their character is really something
to be admired Judd Hirsch does a
surprisingly hilarious Dracula voice I
will get even with you for this award if
it takes me about a year and I know how
to make you live that long and Mariette
Hartley is great as his cynical nemesis
but quickly my wife shorty to say is
laughably cheesy will be an
understatement he'll it ends with a
disco party but it's surprisingly heavy
on atmosphere and even manages to get in
a few laughs here and there for
something obviously intended for little
kids there's just enough to xarna s--
and of course love for Halloween that
makes it a fun little goofy tale it's
like a g-rated monster squad which is
strange the adult film stars kids but
the kid film stars adults but you get
the idea if you're in the mood for
something awkward but enjoyably awkward
this is definitely one to watch it's one
of those days I wish I was then and hey
babe number nine
the pumpkin that couldn't smile
yeah that's Raggedy Ann and Andy whose
star in it but to its credit it turns
out a very laid-back and kind of
likeable short with a lot of great fall
visuals and overbearing odd keeps her
nephew in for Halloween ruining is fun
so our two ragdolls decide to bring
Halloween to him by finding a glum
pumpkin who feels unwanted I know it
sounds pretty lame on the surface but
throwing animation great Chuck Jones
into the mix as well as some legendary
voice actors it turns out an enjoyably
cute product there's lines that
certainly aren't laugh-out-loud funny
but are still clever enough to know
there was more effort put into this than
there really needed to be and tomorrow
we'll go to the museum and look at the
rocks people don't expect so much other
Apple little giggles like that and the
pumpkin crying seeds are nice little
touches that aren't needed for a story
like this but still add a little extra
the best way I can describe this special
is mellow it is just so mellow
everything goes at a very relaxed speed
even the chase scene in the middle is
much much slower than most cartoon
chases go but there's something kind of
chill about it and I mean that actually
in the best way it's not trying to punch
you in the face like most Halloween
specials it's more enjoying a beautiful
autumn dawn just admiring the colors in
the environment I don't know if you're
in the right mood it's actually pretty
cool to check out by no means a
masterpiece of animation but just
comforting enough to warrant a quick
march if you get the time I could've
gotten another line of work then a pie
or something
number 8 which is night out and odds
special to say the least but it's 70s
odd we should practically be given its
own category to say its style is friggin
bizarre is beyond obvious but the way
it's bizarre makes it hard to turn away
from its entrance around a which played
by Gilda Radner who feels her powers of
scaring have dwindled down to nothing
but she here's a little boy and a little
girl wishing they could be scary
themselves and so she transforms them
and their babysitter into classic spooks
of course things get out of control and
it's a crazy race to try to set things
back right again everything that makes
this special unique is the time period
it was released in I mean look at it how
could this come from any other time
period but the 70s from the groovy music
to the squiggly designs and even the
voice acting being really fuckin weird
yeah malicious it's in a world all its
own something about these kind of
specials have an almost hypnotic power
to them I remember watching and not
thinking it was really anything great
but at the same time I didn't want to
change the channel I never felt like I
was being manipulated or sold anything I
just felt like a crazy person was
telling a crazy story in a crazy way and
oddly enough I was curious how crazy it
could get it's not - trippy that you
can't follow it but it's also not too
bound to the world of the norm
it's just cosmically and sane enough to
hold ones interest after coming off a
sugar high every Halloween that's hot
number seven corpse bride people are
kind of split on whether or not this is
a good movie but no one can deny it's
dripping with gothic atmosphere that
made Nightmare Before Christmas a
classic the story about a young man who
accidentally proposes to a dead bride is
refreshingly original as well as
refreshingly strange it's nice to see a
story like this that feels a little bit
like a fairy tale but isn't a reboot or
a remake it's something completely out
of the mind of someone else the look
also very cleverly satirizes the
Victorian era as showing it being more
dead and unlikely than the world of the
dead an interesting idea that you don't
really start living until you give up
everything you thought mattered with
that said it is flawed with a boring
villain bland leads and sometimes clumsy
delivery it strange to that expression
out of Jack Skellington who has no eyes
and yet so little expression out Johnny
Depp's character who has huge eyes I
think that's because even though they're
big they change very little and once
combined with a tiny mouth that also
allows for very little expression you
don't get much variety out of their
reactions which makes them harder to
relate to but like I said there's still
a lot of great stuff that makes it worth
of clamps it has new songs from Danny
Elfman a lot of great actors and
naturally it looks amazing this is one
of Tim Burton's best-looking films and
that's saying a lot giving his lineup
flowing animation and original subject
matter makes it maybe not Coraline or
ParaNorman but still an interesting
flick to check out
another six Grinch night as much as I've
praised dr. Seuss I'll be the first to
say just like anyone he didn't always
turn in gold grin tonight was a
follow-up to the Grinch who stole
Christmas and tried to become a staple
of Halloween the same way the other one
became a staple of Christmas it didn't
really work the story made little sense
it was hard for younger kids to follow
and it just didn't seem very focused
however that doesn't mean a lot of
really cool things didn't come from it
seeing dr. Seuss take on a dark all
night during Halloween is about as
awesome as it sounds and the whole last
third is just an acid trip into the
tricks and frights that the Grinch is
going to unload on the town it's about
as trippy as it gets it might even get a
few scares out of little kids which i
think is the idea the imagery is surreal
and breathtaking this is obviously an
excuse just to get out some dark and
twisted art work but it's so wonderfully
creative that you're kind of okay with
it look at this stuff who else could
come up with this but dr. Seuss the
shorts not terrible by any means it just
doesn't feel like I had a reason to
exist but for what it's worth it's one
of the most amazing-looking pointless
outings ever definitely feeding you some
visual eye candy watch the opening for
atmosphere stay for the trip out near
the end it's a Grinchy Grinch time to
see the least I wouldn't go out on a
night
for a dollar and fifty cents
hey Doug Walker here just got fast
announcement I will be doing a Q&A a
YouTube Q&A in the comments for the
trailer of nostalgia critic be awesome
you can check that out there it is gonna
be from let me see here uh 3:30 p.m.
Central time to five o'clock Central
Time
we are also gonna do two free downloads
as well so I said just click on the
little area there and hopefully I'll be
able to answer you guys questions I will
see you there
take care number five
Garfield's Halloween adventure what can
you say its Garfield how can you go
wrong with it shut up it's our favorite
fat cat roaming the town trying to get
candy while coming across a band of
ghost pirates searching for their lost
stolen treasure the Pirates aren't even
really that scary but the time they take
to build them up by having a creepy old
man tell their story is just the right
amount of corny and creepy for most kids
but that's not what makes it rewatchable
what brings us back is Lorenzo music as
Garfield
I swear that voice is so infectious at
being both lazy and energized at the
same time we can be candy candy candy
candy camp Kenny steady yourself
Garfield he has the cranky cynicism of
an adult but the creamy hyperactive
nasai child dogs have to help cats go up
and get candy and if the dog does a good
job he gets a whole piece of candy of
his very own the special also has a lot
of little funny touches to like how many
various ways they can show a monster
disguise is really a monster disguised
the animation is low-budget and
sometimes the timing can be off but
there's just a passion and a love for
Halloween that makes it hard not to put
on again always good to celebrate this
time of year with little orange and
black nice touch
the Halloween tree how often do you come
across a Halloween special that actually
teaches you something well that's
exactly what this one does and it
surprisingly does it very well based on
the story by ray bradbury the soul of a
friend is lost on Halloween night adds
up to his friends to try and get him
back along with the help of a ghoulish
creature played by the late Leonard
Nimoy though by God you would never
recognize him it's old time children
ancient times as they travel through
time of Halloween's past they come
across the origins of their classic
costumes and figure out how it got
associated with the holiday and as you'd
imagine it's actually pretty interesting
on top of that for a hanna-barbera
production it looks pretty damn good we
always associate hanna-barbera with the
Flintstones and cheap animation but here
the backgrounds and shadows are so crisp
and so clear allowing for a lot of great
Halloween imagery does it have problems
yeah it can be really corny and a little
too obvious as well as kind of
repetitive just count how many times
this kid says oh my gosh
but the payoff is certainly enough to
give it some attention it's great to
enjoy all the awesome things about the
holiday but it's also good to know
sometimes where they came from and the
special shows that in a very inventive
way in a world where education can be
scary this is a special that tones down
the freights and helps the learning but
amazingly you know good
number three Monster House
another really original idea that's so
simple and yet most people never forget
it it's about exactly what you think a
Monster House
one that gobbles up anybody who walks by
and pisses it off while imaginative you
would think it would get old really
quick but there's actually a pretty
clever story that has a few twists and
turns in it it's not overly complicated
but it's not insultingly simple either
it's just the right balance of a dark
and twisted story with goofy and likable
characters and of course visually they
up the darkness skinny trees scary faces
people in peril it has a lot of fun at
times it can be a little slow and the
character animation could be a little
awkward given the time period it came
out but the various ways they show off
this house and change it around to make
everyday objects suddenly look
intimidating is really cool it's a good
combination of being both creepy and odd
but also sweet and innocent at the same
time with just the right amount of an
edge for kitchen you want to regain to
live it's another flick you have to
praise for its originality and its
dedication to an idea it's not laugh
riot or anything but there's enough in
it to keep coming back for a few more
house warnings
number two
Trick or Treat so on the one hand there
really isn't a lot to this movie it
always feels like there's better twists
and executions than an anthology of
Halloween tale could deliver than this
they're kind of predictable and not
always the most original but with acid
trick-or-treat is just straight-up
Halloween porn
I mean before was straight-up Halloween
pork when you really think about all the
horror films that we watch on Halloween
there's surprisingly aren't that many
that have much Halloween in it even
Halloween doesn't have a whole lot of
Halloween it's actually kind of odd but
with this movie it's in every corner
foreground/background werewolves witches
trick-or-treaters ghosts this movie is
just crawling with Halloween and on top
of that they know how to shoot Halloween
everything looks warped and strange with
a lot of great angles and dark shadows
but there's also a fair amount of color
in it too
the right colour is Halloween colors if
you were to ask me what this film was
about I probably couldn't remember very
well but if you were to ask me what it
looked like I can just tell you it looks
like Halloween I guess it's kind of like
the Halloween 3 of its day
not much on scares but a shit ton of
sugar coated visual madness they even
throw in some new monsters like this
killer trick-or-treating kid is actually
have an original idea most movies is the
trick-or-treat our being shades it's not
usually the trick-or-treat our doing the
chasing it's hard to know what else to
say about it it just obviously loves the
holiday as much as the rest of us do and
it's hard to fault it for that hell I
appreciate it what it really is a fun
flick to watch if only just to watch it
you could put it on mute and still get a
satisfying surge of Halloween from
beginning to end it just fills you up
with that awesome feeling while still
having that intense edge it's not a
perfect film but it's a perfect
exploitation of everyone's favorite
and the number one Halloween
guilty-pleasure is no no no no no no I'm
not doing that one I'm not doing it but
that's a dumb film it's a stupid fucking
film okay look I don't care if most of
you watch this piece of crap every
Halloween and it's like a big tradition
okay I'm not doing it I'm just not
talking about it it's shit
it's a stupid piece of shit and I'm not
gonna bring it up here okay well if
there's a Halloween guilty-pleasure that
you watch every year and I didn't bring
it up go ahead leave it in the comments
below but there is no way I am talking
about this piece of fuck especially in
the next review
you
hey guys Doug Walker here doing the
charity shout out as some of you may or
may not know one of our former producers
Lyndsey Ellis recently lost her father
to Parkinson's disease in lieu of
flowers she has invited people to make
donations to the Michael J Fox
foundation so there's the charity that
we are doing this week the Michael J Fox
foundation as many of you know is a
foundation trying to make breakthroughs
in curing Parkinson's disease they try
to raise awareness they try to get more
information about the disease to people
who don't know that much about it but
most importantly they put the research
to work they use it to try and make new
drugs to help people with the disease
they do everything in their power to try
and create easier ways of living with it
they have fundraiser after fundraiser
and all sorts of events that get in so
much money and get so much work
accomplished but as you know we're still
not at the point where we can cure it
yet there have been so many stories of
so many people that have gone through so
much hardship from this disease the pain
so many these people have to go through
is so emotional and so gut-wrenching but
at the same time it's a reminder of just
how real this disease is and how hard we
have to work to find a cure for it
Michael J Fox has done a wonderful job
drawing attention to this cause getting
more and more people involved and on top
of that if you go to their YouTube site
you can see what they do with their time
where all the effort and money goes into
just spending a few minutes watching a
few videos you can see this is
definitely a good place a place where
people work endlessly to try and get to
a day where we can live without this
disease it's something people should
never have to go through and so many
people are trying so hard to create a
world where they don't have to go
through it so please definitely take the
time to check out the website look up
some information watch the videos see
the good work that they're doing and
take a part in helping by making a
donation this is a cure that can happen
with your help
you